toca
o no
la más frío
[Música]
tráenos a la chica y saldará su deuda es
con estas palabras que comienzan de los
mejores y más entrañables juegos de los
últimos años varios soc infinite con un
pie sencillo proyectivo y una historia
increíble este brillante y fantástico
juego es fácilmente uno de los mejores
juegos de los últimos años y sin duda
alguna un juego que cualquiera diría un
huevo aunque sea una vez en su vida
con esto ha aclarado hay que admitir que
hay varias cosas en infinite que te
juegan la cabeza y no prestar la
suficiente atención siendo una de estas
obviamente la historia y su confuso y
ambiguo final pero también hay muchas
otras cosas en este juego que te
perderás sin nuestro atento que van
desde las más simples y curiosas hasta
las que te hacen ver todo el cariño que
le pusieron al juego así que deja lo que
sea que estés haciendo y relájate porque
vamos a ver publicidad de secretos y
detalles de bioshock infinite
[Música]
y una de las primeras palabras que
escuchamos en el juego y la frase que
nos da la bienvenida a la ciudad
flotante de columbia es is it someone
new es alguien nuevo palabras que hace
referencia a la misma frase dicha por un
esplai ser cuando entramos por primera
vez en un rap sur en el país original
whitson
es el salmón
el creador de paddle yo que eleva en
receso les di a trabajar en varios autos
porque después del éxito que fue el
primer baile yo quería enfocarse en su
siguiente título un juego con un enfoque
muy distinto al del primero siendo este
valioso que infinite él y su equipo
comenzaron a trabajar en el juego
después del lanzamiento del primer baile
bajo el nombre de proyecto icarus para
citar cualquier clase de filtración y
mantener el desarrollo del juego en
secreto al inicio del juego los hermanos
luces nos llevarán al faro que nos
conducirá hasta colombia mientras vamos
a explorar nuestro faro nos
encontraremos eventualmente con el
cadáver de alguien en una silla que
tendrá una nota en la que se puede leer
no nos decepciones trituramos un poco
más encontraremos una carta de comstor
donde la encarga a esta persona el
trabajo de asesinar a booker lo que
quiere decir que este tipo de naves y no
enviado por comstock pero los hermanos
ruth es lo mataron antes de que nosotros
llegáramos todo esto para darnos más
oportunidad de lograr nuestro cometido
en cierta parte del juego podemos ver a
robert lutts pintando rosalind pero si
ponemos atención nos daremos cuenta que
en realidad se está pintando a sí mismo
más allá de una broma esto corre sentido
si recordamos que robert y rosa en el de
ustedes no son hermanos son la misma
persona de diferentes realidades varios
o quien fini tiene muchísimos conceptos
que fueron descartados durante su
desarrollo cosa que por ejemplo se
refleja en su gran cantidad de enemigos
descartados enemigos como los freaks
personas comunes cabida recurrió al
canibalismo y consecuentemente inmutaba
en horribles criaturas con único
objetivo de casarnos los magos enemigos
que poseían telequinesis y la capacidad
de convertir a los habitantes de
columbia en sus aliados los fundidos o
emergentes habitantes de la ciudad de
columbia que habrían sido afectados por
un desgarro espacio-temporal
provocándoles locura y múltiples
desfiguraciones en todo su cuerpo los
resolutores productores y muchos otros
que para bien o para mal no llegaron
hasta en la versión final del juego
otro pasado eliminado el juego pero nos
vídeo el yanquis personas que abusaron
del uso los visualizadores volviéndose
adictos con un consumo excesivo esta
sustancia provocando mutaciones y
deformidades en todo su cuerpo además de
la capacidad de atacarnos con distintas
clases de vigorizador es hay pequeñas
líneas de dialogo ocultas que le
pertenecen a los hermanos lotes podemos
abrirlas en la parte donde estos mismos
personajes nos ofrecen el escudo
tratamos de golpearlos o incluso
dispararles a lo que ellos responderán
burlándose nosotros por nuestra
capacidad de causarles daño
porque no puedo hacer nada
algo similar ocurre con él y sabe por
qué como espero que ella es una mujer
fuerte y no se aguantan los jueguitos de
nadie ya que si tratas de apuntarle con
tu arma ella se apartará el camino
regaña no te paso por apuntar tu arma
tan adorable criatura
hathaway cuando conocemos al alistado y
tenemos nuestro primer encuentro con
ella él y saben sorprender se suelta un
libro de sus brazos ciento de este lado
y sea referenciando el final inconcluso
y ambiguo tanto el la odisea como el
infinito pero luego de que caemos el isr
asustada comienza a arrojar los más
libros curiosamente siendo estos libros
que nos lanza y con el que trata de
atacarnos el mismo libro los principios
de la mecánica cuántica escrito por los
lotes libro que habla sobre la partícula
luces y el campo luces los principios
cuánticos descubiertos por los hermanos
entre muchas otras cosas permitirán que
la ciudad de columbia se mantuviera
suspendida en el aire
él vigorizador del beso del [ __ ] que
es de los primeros que conseguimos en el
juego pero curiosamente mejorarlo al
máximo tendrá un coste 666 águilas de
plata en otra para temprana del
desarrollo de para eso infinita tiene
una idea completamente distinta de los
vigorizador es ya que en un principio no
iban a ser líquidos que podríamos beber
para adquirir sus peculiares habilidades
sino que tenía planeado otros
vigorizador estuvieron una forma de
brazaletes con agujas que se verían a tu
muñeca inyectando un flujo constante de
energía esto con muchas otras cosas en
el juego se cambió por las similitudes
con el primer bioshock y sus plásticos
ya que para este juego querían conceptos
totalmente nuevos alejados de los antes
vistos rapture el primer priorizado que
adquirimos en el juego es posesión que
nos permite manipular a nuestros
enemigos por un corto periodo de tiempo
cada vez que lo usamos podemos ver los
susurros de una mujer en voz baja que no
son muy claros pero si reproducimos
estos mismos susurros en reversa nos
daremos cuenta de que en realidad es un
fragmento de romeo y julieta
[Música]
aún más curioso es que cuando usamos
posesión en un enemigo la silueta
fantasmal de una mujer aparecerá
alrededor de nuestro enemigo
susurrándole estas palabras para que al
final en un paralelismo con los
personajes de la misma obra terminen
suicidándose
[Música]
el de ls de panteón marino episodio 2 al
comienzo veremos que los hermanos
ustedes nos llevan sobre un bote
mientras discuten por si prestamos
atención al océano porque estamos
pasando podemos ver que hay decenas de
cuerpos sin vida flotando si no todos
estos cuerpos
elisabeth
existen algunas eras ocultas que son
bastante difíciles de ver pero las que
se puede hacer jugando un poco con el
código del juego estas zonas pueden
contar casi el fin del juego cuando dice
que nos lleva al mar de puertas aquella
zona donde todas las realidades se
conectan son tres zonas ocultas en total
dentro del código el juego a las que
podremos acceder un foro ubicado en el
desierto una estación espacial y un
observatorio ubicado en las montañas
nevadas se puede tratar de entrar a
estos lugares pero conocer las puertas
se producen error en el juego estas tres
zonas están planeadas para ser usadas en
esta misma parte de la historia donde
liza nos explica todo sobre las
realidades alternas pero al final son
descartadas se ocultaron dentro del
código del juego
google desert court broker es el nombre
y la bella canción que hace parte de la
banda sonora del juego pero esta canción
no es original de poder sin fin
originalmente esta canción es un popular
y uno cristiano escrito en 1907 por
adaja versión dada la de la composición
original esta pasó a ser de dominio
público así que los creadores del juego
incluyeron esta canción en su obra dado
que añadía un muy buen elemento la
ambientación del juego además de por la
amplia relación que tiene la lista de la
canción con la historia del país
infinito se hicieron varias versiones
totalmente nuevas de esta canción con
algunos cambios con respecto al original
para ser usadas adecuadamente en el
juego de hecho podemos escuchar una de
estas versiones al inicio del juego
cuando llegamos por primera vez a
columbia dándonos una siniestra pero
hermosa bienvenida
[Música]
la primera vez que vemos a elizabeth es
a través de un cristal sin que ello
pueda vernos durante estos momentos
somos testigos de cómo ella verá un
desgarro hacia otra realidad lo curioso
es que podemos ver a través de este
desgarro que en los cines de parís se
está proyectando la revancha del iaj
esto es un claro guiño hacia star wars
de carangas el día y fue el título a
originalmente el episodio 6 de star wars
antes de que george lucas le cambiara el
título al retorno del jedi
durante el desarrollo del juego se
barajaron muchísimas ideas sobre qué
clase de personas debería ser elizabeth
yo considerar la idea de hacer que el
istat fuera completamente muda al igual
que nuestro personaje sin que ninguno de
los dos tuvieron ninguna línea de
diálogo en todo el juego
esto fue pensado así porque no querían
que elízaga se convirtió en un personaje
molesto para los jugadores pero después
de pensarlo decidieron que no sería una
buena idea porque con la coprotagonista
del juego siendo muda sería muy difícil
entender muchas de las cosas que ocurren
además de que no sería un personaje tan
carismático además de esto al inicio del
desarrollo los poderes de alistar eran
muy distintos ya que además de abrir
desgarros elisabeth tenía telequinesis
poder que sería de mucha ayuda en los
combates cosa que incluso se puede
vencer en algunos de los trailers
promocionales del juego pero al final
todos estos conceptos fueron cambiados
porque le iban pararle un tono no tan
oscuro a su hora obteniendo así analizar
que todos conocemos
desde que voy a varias ocasiones por
primera vez pude darme cuenta fácilmente
que elisa es un persona muy especial no
sólo por ser quien te acompaña durante
todo el juego sino también porque es un
personaje lleno de carisma y que le da
vida al juego esto se evidencia
mayormente en la playa si estando aquí
en vez de seguir el objetivo principal
de ambos un poco por ahí revistas
comenzar a interactuar con todo a su
alrededor
justo como una niña curiosa por el mundo
que nunca le permitieron conocer
[Música]
jones
watch des
muy bien
en marzo del 2012 ese reloj la fecha del
lanzamiento del juego que sería
originalmente en octubre de ese mismo
año pero debido a la complejidad en
general ya que el equipo de desarrollo
del juego quería más tiempo para pulir
ciertas cosas llegaron a retrasar la
fecha de lanzamiento del juego hasta
tres veces sino estrenado finalmente en
marzo del 2013 casi un año después de su
fecha original es más porque en tu kylie
sobre si esto y como nos encanta manejar
todo con humor no perder una oportunidad
de incluir una referencia a estos
numerosos retrasos del juego dentro del
mismo juego
[Música]
y varios instrumentos
en el juego existe el modo 1999 que se
mueve con la dificultad más alta puede
crear razón de que varios jugadores se
quejaron de que los dos primeros barrios
fueron bastante sencillos y no
presentaban ningún desafío se puede
bloquear de dos maneras ya sea pasando
del juego o la pantalla de inicio se
introduce el código con amigo elmo 1999
obtiene su nombre de systems 2 puedo
crear por el mismo equipo de pavés o que
infinity que tenía forma de ser un juego
bastante difícil que fue senado en 1999
pero es nuestro único juego secretos del
juego 0451 es un código que es bastante
común en varios juegos y valioso que
infinite no es la sección la razón de
que esté presente en este juego es
porque está en el código de la puerta de
entrada del looking las estudios lugar
donde a quién le va en creador de padres
yo comenzó su carrera a lo largo de todo
el juego nos encontraremos con melodías
que nos resultarán bastante familiares
en distintos lugares que usaremos
canciones muy conocidas pero cómo es
posible esto si luego se ambientan
muchos años antes de que todas estas
canciones frank siquiera creadas bueno
esto se explica en los box o foros que
encontraremos cerca a la casa de comptos
donde se nos dice que albert zink se
topará con algunos desgarros espacios
temporales dejados accidentalmente por
elisabeth a través de estos desgarros al
ver escucharía la música del futuro de
otras realidades luego escuchar estas
canciones
solo se encargaría de copiarlas y
adueñarse de ellas después con los
escucharemos distintas versiones de
canciones de artistas como cindy lauper
otros 'beach boys'
ah
[Música]
en varios o tiff y sus de él es de
panteón marino podemos encontrar
bastantes referencias al primer baile
una de esas referencias es raptor
récords una tienda de música que podemos
encontrar en el capítulo 1 de panteón
marino y en el juego principal podemos
encontrar dentro de la casa de compton
un disco de vinilo con la marca raptor
récords
en un gameplay promocional para el juego
estrenado en 2010 podemos encontrarnos
con saltones todo un político de
colombia y miembro de los fundadores
quien sería originalmente un villano de
la historia pero que no llego a ser
parte del juego final a pesar de haber
sido removido del juego y de su historia
principal aún existen diálogos en donde
se le hace referencia
[Música]
además de parecer su cabellera clavada
en un cartel con las personas que el
objetivo de los rebeldes vox populi
a lo largo del juego se nos da la opción
de tomar distintas decisiones en varios
momentos pero curiosamente ninguna de
estas decisiones importa porque sea cual
sean las decisiones que tomemos no
afectan absolutamente en nada al que
implicó a la historia en sí esto fue
hecho a propósito por los
desarrolladores para un claro ejemplo de
las constantes y las variables que
nuestras pequeñas decisiones las
variables como te conté antes en este
juego hay bastantes referencias del
primer varios o siendo de las más
destacables las numerosas llaves
inglesas que encontraremos a lo largo
del juego referenciando las que usamos
en el primer título además de que en
ciertas partes de influir encontraremos
carreras de bebé con municiones o armas
esto es un guiño al momento en el primer
beso donde veríamos acciones puede ser
hablarle dulcemente a su bebé dentro de
una carriola pero que después veríamos
que es el arma que usaríamos en el juego
[Música]
no
uno de los momentos más impactantes de
la historia es como después de perder
alistar abrimos un desgarro para tratar
de salvar las de las manos de comptos
solo parar nos cuenta desde que habíamos
llegado muy tarde después de una charla
ella nos entrega una carta con un
mensaje cifrado para la liza vez del
pasado
esta carta contiene símbolos en los que
no les damos mucha importancia pero
cuando usamos el tablero que tenía
elizabeth en la torre para cifrar el
mensaje esto lo que obtendremos
solamente soy un texto en código
probablemente sea cambiado por algo más
importante en el futuro pero de momento
soy solo un sustituto tal vez los
desarrolladores querían poner un mensaje
algo más importante en esta carta pero
seguramente se les olvidó hacerlo
la versión de deslizar queremos en
algunos de los talleres del juego y que
finalmente fue descartada la podemos ver
al final del juego en el momento ante
varias elisabeth de distintas realidades
acompañen a booker para juntos
finalmente romper el ciclo
sound ver es el némesis de varios o
kings después la criatura que nos
perseguirá implacablemente durante todo
el juego si no personaje indispensable
para la historia pero conceptos
iniciales durante el desarrollo son ver
iba a ser originalmente en montmeló el
hombre polilla algo así como un victoria
gigante con las mecánicas adheridas a su
cuerpo
este diseño original de software siente
sino para concernido los jugadores cada
vez que fueran perseguidos por él pero
luego por las similitudes con un víctor
y fue cambiado a su diseño actual
durante la historia del juego se nos
cuestan bastantes cosas sobre schönberg
y su origen pero muchas otras cosas
sobre él son dejar sin respuesta bueno
el de él ese panteón marino estuvimos
que son ver fue creado por jeremy a fin
de columbia y el doctor succión the
rapture mediante los desgarros de
elisabeth estos científicos de distintas
realidades se conocieron y trabajaron
juntos para enseñar asombro a partir de
los diseños de los militares llegando a
experimentar en varios animales e
incluso en cierta parte del de lcd
encontramos planos donde se nos da a
entender que software está creado con
partes humanas
el llanto de software puedes escuchar el
primer payaso durante la escena de
sandler con y el piano
[Música]
a pesar de que esto puede que tenga una
respuesta bastante simple siento éste
solamente un efecto de sonido que se
reutiliza en ambos juegos muchas teorías
ha salido a la luz desde que se
descubrió esto como por ejemplo algunas
donde se dice que existen varias
realidades donde son ver están guacho u
otras donde se dice que esto fue dejado
intencionalmente en el juego amo de
pistas sobre el siguiente para diversión
cuando youtube le pregunto al mismo que
elevan sobre esto él respondió jamás lo
diré
casi al final del juego en el momento
donde son ver muere después de
limpiarnos las lágrimas para poder ver
bien si miramos con atención podemos ver
en el fondo a una luz y estar tratando
de despertar a un fallecido picar y
en la parte del juego donde estamos de
caminos al dirigible con elisabeth nos
encontraremos con un npc que
extrañamente reconoce a liza y la
saludara refiriéndose a ella como anabel
nombre que pertenece a la madre isabel
existe
por un tiempo se pensó que esta mujer
era alguien que de alguna manera dentro
de todo este desmadre interdimensional
reconoce la verdadera elisabeth pero la
verdad más simple que es este personaje
se llama esther mailer y en un box o
fono se nos cuenta que ella fue enviada
por comstock para capturar a elisa y
acabar con buque es por eso que conoce a
na
en el final de la historia si no revela
que no somos el primer mujer que trata
de salvar a elisabeth a lo largo de la
historia ha habido muchas versiones de
booker que han tratado salvarla y han
fallado nosotros él buscará que nosotros
jugadores encarnamos es el booker número
123 esto se ve reflejado en varias cosas
como por ejemplo en el código que nos
dan los hermanos luces para entrar a
columbia o la cantidad de veces que
hemos tirado la moneda que son 122
siendo nosotros la número 123 lo que
quiere decir que los hermanos lotes han
repetido el proceso de buscar a un nuevo
quer y ayudarlo a tratar de salvar a
elisabeth 122 veces antes de contarnos a
nosotros el booker que finalmente
acabaría con todo
[Música]
hay un lugar medianamente oculto debajo
del bar de sant y town y nos
encontraremos una guitarra con la que
podremos interactuar si lo hacemos el
estado de cantar una versión acústica de
seguros de ser cambian broken una de las
canciones más hermosas jamás creadas
dentro de todo lo cura que es este juego
este momento tan simple pero aún así tan
especial así creamos lo asombroso que es
este juego su gran historia sus
entrañables personajes sobre todo
trágicamente bello que es para josh
hopkins finita
pero sin llegar a él
[Música]
y
s
[Música]
para mí
ay
es a perder
como veis
en las calles
e
[Música]
y con esto llegamos al final de las
curiosidades de uno de los juegos con un
exterior suficientemente confusa como
para mover la cabeza a cualquiera aún
así adeuropa your shot infinite sus
personajes tan carismáticos su mundo con
una ambientación tan única su gran
historia todo sino su cabo por eso que
infinite la verdad no sé por qué pues en
el tiempo aquí donde se está buscando la
obra en fin gracias por ver el vídeo a
la nana crees que el vídeo ya había
acabado pues no antes de irme quiero
haceros un poco spam pero el bueno
quiero recomendarles el canal tártaro
music que pertenece a mi amigo y no
tienes un talentosísimo compositor
musical conocido mayormente por su
música celta es el tipo de supremamente
talentoso además de saber tocar varios
instrumentos incluso instrumentos que te
apuesto que no hayas visto en tu vida
pero en serio el hombre es muy muy
talentoso y su música es simplemente
extraordinaria totalmente la pena
escucharla en la descripción dejaré un
link a su canal ahora si esto ha sido
todo mi parte hasta la próxima
[Música]